dessous qui durant cette session nous
abordons donc ces questions qui nous
préoccupent cette situation kazakhstan
et les modalités de normalisation je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit le président loukachenko
en ce qui concerne la situation au
kazakhstan nous comprenons bien que
la demande qu'à lever c'est le prénom
tokayev au conseil de sécurité de décla
b était motivée parce que le fait parce
que ce pays frère et membre de l'aude et
kbc trouver face à une menace sans
précédent pour sa sécurité et nous
comprenons que
dans cette menace pour la stabilité de
l'état il y avait donc des actes isolés
de délinquance mais il y avait surtout
le fait que des forces intérieures et
extérieures profitait de ces troubles
il ya ce qu'ils étaient
qu'ils se servaient de protestation des
contestations liées aux augmentations
des prix du gaz c'est une chose et c'est
une autre chose que ce qui
provoquait des pogroms et des
destructions et donc on avait un soutien
médiatique et informationnels de la
révolte et il y avait des groupes de
combattants armés bien organisés et donc
il y avait un problème d'organisation
qui a été ici qui a été identifié et
cette agression contre le kazakhstan
c'est une agression et nous sommes tout
à fait d'accord et donc il était
nécessaire de réagir rapidement à face à
cette situation et le président
kazakhstan a été tout de suite soutenu
par l'ensemble des présidents du
lot tsc et il est très important que
notre organisation
par la voix du secrétaire général a su
prendre des décisions
en pleine concertation et qui sans même
temps très stricte mais ans je tiens à
préciser qu'en quelques heures nous
avons réussi à nous mettre d'accord au
niveau des autorités nationales pour
éviter une dégradation de la situation
dans l'ensemble du pays et à mettre fin
aux pillages et aux actions violentes
commises par ces terroristes et
au cours de nos discussions
téléphoniques
nous avons vu que les gens ne sais c'est
d'appeler les autorités pour demander
qu'il ya eu une intervention pour lutter
contre les terroristes et les actions
que nous avons menées en commun montre
que c'est un travail de réaction rapide
qui a été fait qui a été concerté et
donc le système de l'opc à pitre réagir
de façon rapide pour envoyer un
contingent de la paie et
j'insiste sur le fait que cela a été
fait pour une durée limitée et qui sera
défini en fonction de la façon dont les
autorités kazakhes le président kazakh
et l'hôtesse et se mettra d'accord et
donc cette ce groupe de soldats de la
paix intervient sur le territoire du
pays pour cette durée délimité et nous
envisageons ces opérations absolument de
façon provisoire
est l'hôte et c
a encore une fois répondu à une demande
officielle qui a été faite par le
président kazakh et que correspond tout
à fait aux statuts de l'opt et
c2 1992 et
dont je vous rappelle que cette
condition est que quand qu'en cas
d'agression contre un pays membre de
l'organisation les autres pays ils
doivent lui
pouvoir lui apporter une aide notamment
militaire
donc là on avait des bandes armées qui
circulait qui malheureux manifestement
avaient été formés à l'étranger et
qu'ils avaient probablement une
expression une expérience de combat dans
d'autres points chauds dans le monde et
donc ici l'hôtel s'est montré qu'elle
était capable de réagir rapidement et de
façon efficace et chaque pays membre de
notre organisation a apporté sa
contribution notamment sur le plan
militaire en mettant à disposition des
troupes et donc
hélas tous les pays membres de
l'organisation ont participé cela montre
que
de cette coopération qui fonctionne
depuis des années
la mise en place scrupuleuse d'un
mécanisme de d'interaction et de
coopération
militaires de maintien de la paix ce
travail qui a été fait pendant des
années a montré donc son résultat
ça veut c'est à dire que les troupes de
nos différents pays participent à des
manoeuvres en commun avec des du
matériel militaire compatible avec des
facilités de projection militaires et
qui sont validées avec dans le cadre de
manoeuvres avec des pays frères et c est
aussi haut sur la base de l'expérience
des militaires russes acquise en syrie
avec une grande maîtrise des armements
et des techniques de combat de façon
concertée et cela montre que nous sommes
capables de réagir face aux différentes
menaces du terrorisme et pour pouvoir
protéger la population et encore une
fois c'est cette activité
d'entraînement militaire qui fait que
nous avons pu dans des délais
extrêmement réduit envoyer un contingent
tout à fait efficace
donc ce contingent est composé de deux
troupes
aéroportées russes et dans le cadre de
cette opération
les troupes aéroportées russes ont sous
les ordres du général andré serdioukov
on peut mener des opérations
tout à fait bien contrôlé en accord avec
les autorités kazakhes c'est important
parce que le kazakhstan
et ses forces de police et de justice
travaillent directement dans cette
préparation
de réaction aux menaces et donc ce sont
les fonctions régaliennes de l'état de
kazakhstan qui sont assurées ici
et
le but de l'opération est justement que
le président kazakh plus exercer
continuent à exercer ces fonctions
et
avec notre soutient donc la situation
kazakhstan redevient à peu près normale
l'activité de l'aéroport de nursultan a
été complètement
débarrassée des forces terroristes qui
étaient sur place
grâce à la police et à l'armée grâce à
ce temps et grâce aux efforts en commun
que nous avons fait bientôt la situation
sera complètement stabilité sur
l'ensemble du territoire du pays et les
habitants pourront revenir un mode de
vie normale
ce n'est ni la première ni la dernière
tentative d'agression et de
déstabilisation du pays et les mesures
prises dans le cadre de l'hôtesse et
montre que ces tentatives de
déstabilisation
au connaîtront une réponse efficace et
rapide tout le monde sait que
à notre époque d'utilisation des réseaux
internet etc
d'autres tentatives de déstabilisation
ont lieu contre nos citoyens
et qu'ils peuvent précéder est
annoncée donc des opérations terroristes
comme l'a dit aujourd'hui le président
de casa on a donc une chronologie très
défini des événements elle est très
manifeste tout le monde le voit et de
plus l'expérience des derniers
événements de kazakhstan montre
justement que c'est là le cyberespace
est très utilisé pour le recrutement
d'éléments terroristes le la le réveil
de cellules dormantes et le secrétariat
du conseil de sécurité de l'autre tc a
donc des groupes de travail spécialisés
en matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
qui sont ici très vigilante et donc
c'est un travail de préparation que nous
faisons ensemble sur l'ensemble des
zones de responsabilité de tester ce qui
est important c'est que cela
ces événements tragiques que ce peuple
frère du kazakhstan connaît aujourd'hui
il vous faut que toutes les forces
soient mobilisés ici pour résister à
toutes ses formes de provocation
je voudrais noter aussi que
le noter le courage avec lequel
le président tokayev a à assumer ses
responsabilités il a su consolider
autour de lui
la population les citoyens les forces de
police des forces armées et je suis
convaincu que les autorités du
kazakhstan ferons tout ce qu'il faut
pour rétablir
un mode d'activité normale de la police
deux des fonctions économiques de l'état
et en conclusion je tiens à souligner
que la russie prête à accorder la plus
grande attention à la coopération
stratégique avec le peuple frère du
kazakhstan et je suis convaincu que les
autorités du peuple frère du kazakhstan
seront tout à fait capable de faire face
à cette situation
et à surmonter tous les obstacles je
vous remercie pour votre attention
à l'issue
[Musique]
des collèges aux jeunes collègues
prions retient bonne humeur dépréciateur
historique à 504
jamin timmins ontario
nagy-bocsa malaise nécessitant victime
sa me